con síntomas leves similares a los de un
resfrío así describió el palacio de
buckingham el estado de salud de la
reina isabel 2a quien a sus 95 años
acaba de contraer el cob y 19 en un tuit
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson dijo a hablar en nombre de todos
los británicos
estoy seguro de que hablo en nombre de
todos al desear que su majestad la reina
se recupere rápidamente de kobe y vuelva
a gozar de una buena salud hace unos
diez días la reina se reunió con su hijo
el príncipe carlos y su esposa camila
antes de que ellos también dieran
positivo desde entonces ha hecho varias
apariciones públicas enviando una señal
tranquilizadora a una población
preocupada dada la edad de la soberana
pero el anuncio de su prueba positiva
angustió a más de uno tiene que mejorar
no podemos permitirnos perderla todavía
es un icono es el icono del reino unido-
es una personificación del reino unido-
en cierto modo la mayoría de la gente
del país nunca ha conocido a otra
monarca que no sea ella así que encarna
al reino unido- de muchas maneras
entonces cualquier cosa que ocurre su
detrimento es también en detrimento del
país todo el mundo debe preocuparse
isabel segunda es la monarca que más
tiempo lleva reinando en el país este
año es el de su jubileo de platino que
marca sus 70 años en el trono el pasado
mes de octubre la reina fue
hospitalizada sin que se revelara el
motivo